2020 has been quite an interesting year
for so many people
and then for both of you you both gave
birth to baby boys this past summer
i mean what's it like having babies
during a pandemic
no i have to say it's really scary
i just like think of my experience with
birdie and it
just felt a little more carefree i felt
like i wasn't
i mean i was worried about things
obviously but not as much where
having babies and pandemic you feel like
you're constantly like if they
sniff a certain way or they itch their
nose you're like
oh my gosh are they sick are they fine i
just was a little scarier this time for
me
it does i mean you definitely are just
on edge
so much i mean anything you do and even
for yourself
um even when you're pregnant so i'm
ready for 2021
let's bring it on i'm ready to start a
new year
so i was going to say you know this year
has just aside from everything else
going on globally i mean you guys have
both just been
so busy so how are you feeling right now
at the end of 2020
as you said you're ready for the new
year
you know nikki was saying that we're
just ready for the holidays and we're
like we're gonna make the holidays
really special we're going to dress up
even though we'll be home
we're going to just be a little more
glam because we feel like we've been so
comfy
2020 i mean and then you know
yeah with everything but we just
i feel like now my baby's going you know
this is the bella's new life the bella's
household right now
we we want to end 2020 like glamorous
very glam and just kind of the one thing
that we've learned during this pandemic
is to slow down because we are such
workaholics so we heard
the positives of this pandemic and we're
going to take those with us
yeah i love that i think that's
something that i feel a lot of people
are learning is to to appreciate the
slowdown
so even just like the meaning of like a
true cup of coffee
with the people that you live with to
sit and have that morning conversation
like
i don't think i could ever change that
now like yeah
i really have enjoyed it now season six
uh was postponed obviously due to the
pandemic so what kind of precautions did
you guys have to
take in order to get the season out for
the fans so we
all so we had a small crew and then
whoever was cast which just was bree and
i
are adam and brian like the neighbors um
we all had a quarantine for 14 days like
no grocery store
nothing in our homes 14 days straight
and then and same with the crew they
brought them to an airbnb's and they
could only be two per
airbnb all those quarantine 14 days we
all took tests
and then any time we filmed the only
rule was like you had to come to the
twins house then go back home
twins house go back home we had someone
go get us all groceries
and that was pretty much how we filmed
the like half of the season was like
in that tight of a bubble and so um
it was it was tough especially just
being pregnant
and um just being so on edge but i mean
we made it work i feel like it
made us all closer right yeah it did
actually
oh i love that now brie buddy is your
second
child and nikki mateo is your first so
how would you just
how would you say motherhood has changed
you
uh i feel like i've become so selfless
like it is crazy to me all the things
that mattered so much
and then since matteo's been here like
they don't at all like he is first
and anything that i'm going to do or
think of doing like mateo is the first
thing in my mind and anything that deals
with him it's crazy that
even vanity wise how like so much of it
goes out the door because you just care
about
providing for this child and making them
the healthiest they can be or being
there for them every second
um and i i love that because that love
is like the craziest left ever
it is amazing yeah how much fun is it
watching artem as a dad
oh man it's so cute it's like
i i it's just i guess like you never
see right your guy in this situation and
then when you it's like you find them so
much more
adorable or you fall more in love with
them because things that they do
you're just like oh my gosh it's so cute
and arnold's just like he's just so
sweet and gentle
like arnhem and i literally look like
prairie dogs in the bed every time a
tail makes the noise like we both pop
our heads up like is okay
okay um so it's like hilarious
yeah i love that yeah okay
what would you say is the best lesson
you learned from
free about being a good mom
and there's so many so many um
what did i tell you about the opinion
the judgment yeah but there was another
there's something that you gave me that
i was like okay that was
really good advice except like taking
naps with him because i don't do that
i'm trying there was something that you
told me you said it before
earlier like
something physically to do or like no
mental now like
with the baby a mom advice i mean i
always tell moms
like the same kind of thing is that
you're going to hear so many opinions
but only you and your baby yeah
maybe that's it just like you know go
with the flow with what you
like what you and your baby feel like
because that is the one thing that's
been tough is
so many people like you should make him
you should sleep this way and
you get like all these different things
and your head literally wants to explode
especially when it comes to
breastfeeding because that's like a
whole job in itself
so bree's been has kept me really calm
with like you do what you feel like
follow your gut your intuition what does
it say as a mom with your baby
because it is true every mom and baby
are different than like anyone there's
really no one way so i feel like since
i've taken that approach
i don't stress about sleep training or
all these different things that i was
starting to
i just go with the flow of mateo yeah
that's amazing advice um bri you're
saying how season six is very special
so what makes this season stand out from
the rest and
that you're so excited for fans to see
wow that i never let this one be
pregnant
you know i i honestly thought that nikki
just with her journey and everything i
just never thought she was going to be a
mom i just thought those were in the
cards for her
and i think how we both got pregnant
just not knowing and it was an accident
we found out days apart from each other
it gives me bumps right now it was just
to me such a
very like i hate saying twin thing but
it was and
the fact that not only do i get to see
her be a mother now but that i had to go
through this whole experience with her i
i mean for the rest of our lives we're
going to talk about remember when we
were pregnant together
during a pandemic i know um
so for me that's like just something so
special that nikki and i will have the
rest of our lives and we're so excited
that we get to share it with everyone
else
yeah now this season not only are you
talking about
and showing everyone you know your
pregnancies giving birth
of course there's revelations from your
memoir and and going through the journey
with your mom
and and surgery this past summer would
you say this is the most honest and real
season
oh my gosh definitely because of
everything we all were going through
um you had no choice but to be real like
that
that was it it was like no filters no
dress up
here we are and i think too like what we
like to call in our world is breaking
reality there was so much break in
reality this season
like you said with my mom and just it's
so unpredictable as pregnant women
especially in a pandemic like you have
nothing but raw emotions
and then them being there for the book
drop like this is definitely by far
i would just say it's the non-filtered
season like
the skills it gets the naked truth
do you ever have a fear of letting fans
in too much into your personal lives or
do you just you just go with it
you know i've always been one to go with
it but it's weird ever since i've had
mateo
i'm now told brie i'm like now i have
that fear
of letting in too much just because i
want to protect him
yeah like the first time ever that i
really have thought about like
okay maybe i need to have boundaries now
and like what should i showcase and not
showcase
yeah i feel the same okay now
you as you know viewers of the show
we're gonna be there right with you
as you're giving birth so are you
excited to see those episodes unfold
is that kind of exciting for you guys
have you seen those episodes i haven't
even seen yet my
labor and i'm like dying to see it like
i can't wait to see how all that goes
down
i can't wait to watch her because i'm
like
i can't wait because you know it's such
a blur when you're in there but i had to
have a c-section but you know brian
having a surprise they when they pulled
out
buddy they pulled down the curtain and
they wanted brian to be the first one to
see if we were having a boy or a girl
then he announced it to the surgery room
so i can't wait to see his face when he
sees that it's a boy
and just remember the pitch of his voice
like it's a boy like he was so
surprised so i can't wait to watch that
but we haven't seen it yet
oh that's so exciting is it cool too
thinking that you know your kids will
10 years from now can can go back and
watch these episodes and see that whole
journey
oh my gosh so incredible like they did
that for the rest of their lives
yeah that's very special um brie i want
to ask how birdie's doing with her uh
new baby brother she loves it
like she's such a great older sister i
mean let's be honest she's a three major
so she's
bossy the idea that she gets to be in
charge and boss someone around
but it's cute because like if buddy
cries or anything she'll be like bug
buds crying like go
mama like or she'll sing to him like she
does like just really cute stuff
yeah she's even the same way with mateo
yeah like
just like told me sometimes when he's in
this swing i hide the lamps because he
gets scared of it and she told me she
goes no he likes the lamps
i'm like oh okay my back oh my gosh
that's actually so cute like mom in the
making
oh yes
you